our Milky Way is just one among billions
of galaxies in the universe
it was an honor for me to lend my voice
to such a meaningful film that will
educate audiences but also really
impress them I think it's interesting to
see earth and as large of a scale as
possible and you know IMAX takes about
under the International Space Station
right alongside the astronauts
I've never narrated a film before I've
done voiceover work but always as a
character we knew for a beautiful planet
that we wanted to have a female voice it
just seemed to be the right flavor and
feeling the Colorado River Basin
supplies water to 40 million of us in
seven states the reservoirs that make
this system work are losing water at
alarming rates she was fabulous and is
very very passionate about the subject
climate change is one of the most
important conversations we can have you
know we take too much without giving
back and our planet showing signs of
it's in danger
we have a new generation of cameras so
there's footage that just wouldn't have
been possible without these digital
cameras that we now have so they're like
nightly views of New Zealand and Great
Britain that have just never been seen
before
Tony's wonderful she can tell stories
about science and discovery in a way
that no one else can
and I think we got wonderful wonderful
observations from all of the cruise
a beautiful planet is a love letter to
earth and Tony's film is an attempt to
give back
you